madeleine klein sets the record straight
about her future on outer banks what is
tv without a little drama the 24 year
old actress shut down rumors that she
might be leaving the hit netflix show
after its upcoming third season on
monday saying she has no plans to go
anywhere the denial came in a
since-deleted post to her insta story
quote i will come back for as many
seasons as they will have me i love my
job and there's not a day that goes by
that i'm not grateful for it and for
everyone who has watched it not
everything on the internet is true
rumors surrounding madeleine's future on
the show revved up following her split
from her co-star chase stokes i think
this show does a really good job maddie
and i talked about this a lot
um of an honest authentic take on what
it should be like to be in a young
relationship yeah we definitely wanted
to highlight that like the you know what
a
what a healthy
two-way relationship looks like um
especially for you know for a younger
audience and that was something that we
talked about early on yeah
so
the two started dating after meeting on
set and quarantined together with a few
of their cast mates during the pandemic
we made a giant fort in the living room
we've been kind of every night cooking
meals together so we're we're kind of
making the best out of it the two played
coy when et asked some about their
relationship status in 2020. right now
we are kind of enjoying our time
nothing nothing exclusive we're kind of
just we're friends fast forward to
november 2021 and et confirmed the two
called it quits but the next month a
source told et that they were going to
give their relationship another go quote
madeleine and chase care about one
another they felt like they had to be
apart to get back on track and be
together in the future their
relationship was very serious before and
right now they're slowly easing back
into things and giving it another try
they're not full on back together but
they're taking it slow and seeing where
things go
last month netflix confirms the hit show
is returning for a third season
which will pick up after madeleine's
character sarah tied the knot with
chase's character john b
you know i was thinking
what's that
let's get married
i think that's the john b and sarah away
a little bit yeah
so how will their on-screen marriage
play out in the next season here's what
the pair predicted with e.t back in july
it'd be really fun in season two or
season three
you know if we're if we get one to see
them actually start to like truly get to
know each other
like in a very real sense like
they're married but they actually kind
of don't know a whole lot about each i
feel like that would be really fun what
is it like when they finally get a
second to get to know each other yeah i
feel like that's a really endearing part
about love and i also think when you
know you know
[Music]
you